hey it's Justine and welcome to part 2
of my CES twenty20 coverage there is
still more to see so let's not waste any
time
[Music]
amazon has such a huge presence at CES
mostly because Alexa is enabled in so
many different devices that there's over
a hundred thousand of them there's even
a grill over here that I see it selects
enabled works with Alexa this is
definitely something that I never
thought that I would see here's
something else that I never thought I
would see a robotic lawn mower that's
Alexa enabled this is amazing do you
think that they know that this isn't
real grass wanted to hang out with
samuel l.jackson and you couldn't here's
your opportunity you couldn't change the
voice on Alexa to be samuel l.jackson
you can ask him jokes and all kinds of
fun stuff allow me to welcome actor it
samuel l.jackson i'm in the cloud can
you set a three-second timer sure
one-mississippi two-mississippi
three-mississippi nice right now we're
getting a live cooking demo North IP
Eddie the Amazon has some really cool
on-demand cooking classes that you could
take on your Amazon echo show hello do
you guys see anything edited because I'm
available do you do the editing help I
got the craziest phone call amid all the
holidays and they say do you use Alexa
and I said no but my kids do and they
said well would you like to come cook
with Alexa down in Vegas and I said I've
done weird things that sounds like it's
right up my alley absolutely Alexa read
me this first step squeeze enough fresh
limes to measure 1/2 cup plus 1/4 cup
juice and reserve separately we're gonna
have a little bit of orange juice
add sour orange to my shopping list
please sour orange added to your
shopping list well you can ask me real
quick critical technical tips now huh
this is a little outside way yes
can I get a selfie absolutely
great here you go that's the best part
of the day okay
a little granulated garlic I was so
inspired by the Guy Fieri cooking demo
that I saw over here they have an Amazon
smart oven a while you can airfryer
roast and microwave
morality Elgato
Corsair origin and scuffed boots one of
the things that el gato announced here
at CES is one of these al ghad' oqi
tears what's great about this is you can
just set it right on your desk connected
to Wi-Fi and then you can control it on
your phone or on your computer you can
control the color temperature the
brightness turn it on or off it's really
nicely diffuse so if you are shooting
YouTube videos or if you're a streamer
this is a perfect desk setup they also
announced another thing which will be
available later in the year
this is the elgato 4k 60s and this is
pretty awesome because you can capture
gameplay at 4k 60 also has zero lag 4k
HDR 10 pass through so it leaves your
gameplay unaltered this will allow you
to capture on the go and not need a
computer so for me this is something
that I absolutely love I've always loved
their capture cards and I've been using
them for the past several years so this
is a really great addition especially if
you're doing a lot of game capturing so
this is the XO stuff now if you ever
need to get real comfy help your posture
when you're playing some games
originally I was gonna make fun of us
which is actually incredibly comfortable
ok what this chair is actually quite
comfy as well
so this is of course their concept Orion
is 150 ultra bright ultra efficient
Corsair LEDs it's fitted to a tempered
glass with ultra low visibility film
pretty amazing because normally when you
have LED lights like this you can see
like strips can't even tell where the
LEDs are and where the cases is in order
to decided to make the big o and consume
a reality if you guys saw unbox therapy
unbox the big o it's basically a PC that
also includes a Nintendo switch a
Playstation and an Xbox all in one case
the origin gives you a choice if you
want to have an Xbox or Playstation
mixed in with your PCs you can also
choose to upgrade the consoles hard
drive so you can take out the mechanical
drive and put a solid-state drive in
which will increase your performance so
if I were to customize one of these
obviously I would be going for the Xbox
one sorry now I'm playing on the Xbox
IDE you can also connect dual monitors
so this obviously is attached to the
Xbox and if you want to stream and
capture you can be streaming and capture
over here on the PC side much like most
pcs it's easy to update and on the other
side here you do have a 4k 60 L gato pro
capture card this is great for people
who are
console gamers like me who also want to
be streaming and you don't wanna have
like a crazy big setup and this is the
PlayStation version so you can customize
it if you want to have an Xbox or
Playstation good job origins cool we're
at the short boot that I got a little
gift here so this is their NV 88 plus
video kits this comes with a mic and a
little mount for your phone and a tripod
channel is here too well I've already
unboxed earlier privately private
unboxing we've been here at the end for
several days I haven't even seen Jenna
because she's had separate things to do
I haven't seen you in three days this is
nice
I'm about all over the accessories right
here
[Music]
it's a happy app all downloaded and this
is really cool because in the settings I
can change the direction for CES I'm
probably gonna want to have it kinda
more in a shotgun situation let's get
our vlog on I just got a really cool
microphone but is now attached to my
iPhone I'm at the shore booth and they
gave me one of these to test out and I
want to see what this audio is like
because obviously the iPhone shoots
really great video sometimes the audio
is good but when you're in loud
situations like this being able to
control the degree of where the
microphone is actually picking up audio
is pretty amazing so right now I have it
at 60 degrees and it should be focused
kind of right around here so here's what
it sounds like without using the
microphone there's so much ambient sound
when you're at a conference or a
convention like this that it's really
hard to kind of just pick up my voice
it's not everything else
there's no secret that I'm a Sony
shooter so obviously stopping by the
Sony booth what they did is a seven s
too much right pod is massive
look at this rig they've got the artic
zero on top of the a seminar I'm getting
a lot of rigs Gration for the setup sony
announced a prototype flash concept of
an electric car it's called the vision s
what this prototype vehicle showcases
the best of Sony and one is it had a
total of 33 different sensors from
cameras lidar to ultrasonic sensors
we've introduced things like 360
mayavadi do some great things when it
comes to video displays using the
front-facing and rear-facing camera you
can use the footage from the front or
rear camera you can edit that overlay
music and upload it to your social media
[Music]
things they have for health wellness and
fitness so let's go see what we can find
a lot of times at CES you'll find things
that are just concepts they may never
actually become something real there's
also a lot of things that can look a
little
I'm kind of interested searching for
drug-free relief from back pain I am
actually looking for that so maybe it's
not that strange after all
so these are actually Sleep Number beds
I'm sure you guys are all familiar with
that brand it's really cool because they
have two sides now so you can control
the climate on each side they have a
heating and cooling element you can also
connect your bed to a nap this bed can
also track your heart rate and your
skating with them and this all be right
here on your phone after you wake up in
the morning
oh there's demos I would like to try the
demo but if you think about how many
people have probably laid on that bed
here at the convention center I might
pass wearable biometrics is something
I'm also extremely interested in because
being able to track your heart health
blood pressure and all of those things I
think is very important to know what is
happening with your body cool about this
company is they basically make the tech
that goes into other products are kind
of the industrial secret ingredient and
all of the wearables that you guys see
today
pressure is something that is usually
difficult to track especially having to
carry around the big arm cup well right
now Cory is testing out an ear blood
pressure monitor this looks pretty
interesting so that's way easier than
putting on an arm cups so much easier
and it's less invasive it's less
stressful we think was a really
interesting brand not too long ago they
actually got bought by Nokia but then
they bought themselves back from Nokia
so they're back to we think we have a
Wi-Fi free mark sleeping or lies
nothing to wear I actually have this
it's a thermometer they also have their
blood pressure monitor I even have one
of their scales being able to track and
quantify if you are doing any sort of
like fitness plan or working out being
able to actually track and see changes
it is so important and making sure that
you're doing the right things to reach
your goal so the most innovative Werbach
market for one main reason so it has an
SPO sensor that measures your oxygen
saturation in your glass so naturally
when you sleep your oxygen goes down a
little bit and as people age amended
movement may tend to store more
medication at it you might also have
reading disturbances so not inhaling
oxygen while you sleep it's right at
home and so it's the first wearable in
the market to use an spo2 sensor to help
detect sleep apnea so you see your
oxygen saturation it's out of a hundred
rates between 1900 is considered good
they've color-coded feedback to let
people know what is good and what is bad
it's really great I'm so excited when
does this come out and to kiss you but
his pending FDA clearance so hopefully
by the end the Ebro made so we're hoping
to watch it and be registered that you
have at the same time hey guys can we
work on this we get this cleared because
I need this immediately especially the
sleep tracking because there isn't
anything like this that I've ever seen
yeah and it has a 30-day battery life as
well 30 days I was gonna think I agree
this is awesome I cannot wait until
these are out and available to try
because being able to track all of these
things I think
we are now stepping into the world smart
home tech I was just showing them that
you are on the backwards you made this
this is your product yep yep it is how
cool all this so excited for my daughter
see you on YouTube all the time what's
your name
you know it's exciting too you know like
I was telling you earlier from
entrepreneur to another
I started this part downstairs in Eureka
Park with a big pokey prototyping now
four years later I'm up here so it's so
awesome you give us a demo yeah so
basically it's Benji Locke is how the
world's first edition of padlock with
fingerprint technology and you can open
it with the ease of your fingerprint
but also with a set of traditional piece
so it's still very traditional no app
needed no phone needed if you feel is
pretty heavy substantial it's reliable
the technology to Hampton products and
they're known because they bill all the
Rings lock security so you know that
this is legit and even have bike locks
oh yeah which is really cool because we
look Los Angeles and I'm always riding
on my electric bike like you do so this
is pretty cool you have it's nice and
it's the same technology fingerprint but
also traditional key
thanks so much easier than carrying
around keys because I always lose them
thank you so much for the demo and
congrats Oprah even though I just met
you yeah this is the loss well that's
the beauty of CES you know you just
never know who you're gonna meet in it's
just cool to see innovation and people
like you that what you do I just admire
it because it takes a lot of hard work
so thank you it all balls here at CES
good luck I'm sure I'll see you next
year
[Music]
hey this is a smart body so glad that
they put like a little protector here's
his focus right
is this water yes can I get gonna
constructs I'm so thirsty this is
amazing
so this just filtered yes
now we're gonna head down so you Rica
Park this is one of my favorite places
at CES because this is where you
actually see the future of things that
you see here all of the startup company
is showing some of their demos like
concepts it's amazing we only have about
30 minutes so hopefully we can cycle
through and see some cool stuff right
now everybody's actually leaving because
it's about to close we have 20 minutes
to see as much as we can see
[Music]
America and our financier at Nippon
television please enjoys the yesterday
the chairs providing have to feedback to
what is happening in the game so I'm
gonna go through here and see if I can
find some people and if they you shoot
me I will actually feel it in my back ok
something's happening
I think I'm walking over some rocks so I
can feel that in my legs I think this
guy needs to go away
[Music]
there's so much to see here at Eureka
Park that it honestly is overwhelming
but if you ever do come to CES make sure
you stop by and check out all of the
future tech safety always first we're
gonna check out the S pod not actually
running right now for demos but I'm
gonna sit in it and get a picture the
Segway s pod you guys know that I'm such
a huge fan of Segway ninebot I have
their hoverboard I even have a little
Mario Kart mod that they have for their
little hoverboards but this is the S pod
this is this is it man
I'm going to be cruising around getting
coffee see me pulling up through
Starbucks try through this I'll have a
chai latte please I can't wait to try
this out for real
all right CES is over I'm just gonna sit
here for the next year
you
[Music]